bodies all over the ground next Twisted
faces contorted in Terror
SCP-173 not one but an army scatters out
through site 19 massacring researchers
one broken neck at a time pure chaos how
could this possibly have happened the
strobing of the blood red emergency
lighting was already fear-inducing
enough so it was being hidden under one
of the tables in the mess hall trembling
as the noise of alarms rang out through
the facility but the thing about the
flickering light scared SCP Foundation
researcher Mira Smithy all the more were
the few seconds of Darkness that came
between each flash of red if it had been
any other Containment Breach she
probably wouldn't have even noticed for
in those few seconds when the warning
light lit up only to cut out she
couldn't see a thing and her not being
able to see made it easier for them to
move around Mira had lost track of time
since the alarms had first sounded to
Mark the containment rate she tried to
keep count of the minutes but the
drumming of her heartbeat had thrown her
off there was no way of knowing if it
had been hours or only a few minutes
since everything went wrong of course
the SCP Foundation had plenty of
procedures and protocols in place to
prevent or respond to situations like
this yet the emergency alarms kept
echoing through the corridors lights
plunging the facility Into Darkness
every few seconds only to break it up
with a brief flash of red it seemed to
mirror from her hiding spot that this
breach had proven far too much for the
foundation's extensive procedures to
counteract maybe it was all over already
she thought after a few seconds or maybe
minutes under the table what if they had
gotten bored tired of slaughtering their
way through Foundation personnel and
slunk back to their containment chamber
that would have been simpler far less
terrifying than the alternative that
came creeping into Mira's head in the
form of her next thought what if she was
the only one left alive the last member
of site Personnel still breathing just
by some random hundred to one chance and
if that was the case how long would it
take for them to find her how many even
were there a new sound just detectable
below the alarms broke through her
Avalanche of anxious questions
footsteps the noise of boots clomping
against the floor clearly belonging to a
human and not one of them cautious as to
which way her gaze was directed Mira
poked her head from out beneath the
table glancing around during the few
seconds where the red of the emergency
lights allowed her to see the steps were
getting closer and as they did
researcher Smithy realized something
that made her fearful for her fellow
Survivor they were running away and
there was no way they could do that
while also looking back at what was
coming after them over a year she hissed
in a hush tone at the sight of a pair of
legs crossing a nearby Corridor their
thick standard issue military boots
seemed to match those worn by the
foundation's security Personnel the
officer passed by only to stop and
tiptoe closer to the mess hall having
heard Mira's whispered call with the red
lights blinking it looked like every
other step the security officer took had
been edited out like they were
teleporting closer in the dark watching
intently from her Hiding Place reminded
Meera sickeningly of the things she was
hiding from how they moved and the
worrying fact that she couldn't see one
following the security officer hello
hello other man's voice as he entered
the mess hall under the table we were
whispered if we hide we can still see
them but they can't see us hiding he
replied now we need something I can
revert these things back to the original
I would so much easier to handle when
there was just one of them look let's
make a break for it I'm gonna grab
scp-3108 and get the lights back on if
we can restore visibility we might be
able to stand a fighting chance against
those things the officer was looking
around the cafeteria trying to locate
the source of researcher smithy's voice
eyes distracted then the intermittent
flickering of red light cut off again
plunging the entire mess hall into near
pitch Darkness at the same time there
was the sound of something heavy and
stoned scraping against the flooring it
turned Mira's stomach and she
immediately covered her mouth she had no
idea if they could hear her breathing
could a creature of stone even detect
sound at all well the lights were down
and the security guard's back was turned
a pair of sculptures built from concrete
and rebar traces of spray paint over
their Stone skin appeared behind the
officer at impossible speed there was a
sickening crunch followed by the sound
of something dropping to the floor of
the mess hall as the emergency lights
flicked back on Mira see them the two
copies of SCP-173 standing still next to
the table she was under bathed in red
light this nightmare had all begun as an
otherwise ordinary Friday for the SCP
Foundation only a few hours earlier Mira
had been brainstorming her latest pitch
for a series of experiments involving
scp-914 otherwise known as the
Clockworks scp-914 was a large machine
comprised of various cogs Gyros and
gears of Unknown Origin its function
however had long been documented and was
of great interest to the foundation any
object placed with an scp-914's input
Booth could be transformed destroyed or
improved depending on the clockworks's
setting rough would disintegrate the
subject course would dismantle it to its
base components and one-to-one would
merely replace the object with a similar
almost identical one then there were the
fine and very fine settings the former
would cause scp-914 to improve and any
item and the later is capable of the
same but with one key difference very
fine would refine an object even more
usually by giving it anomalous
properties the foundation higher-ups had
permitted staff to freely conduct tests
using the Clockworks although approval
was required and all data was to be
recorded while many of the scientists at
the foundation were fixed on the
mysterious origin of scp-914 or the
furthest extent of its refinement
capabilities Myra had been thinking
about it in a far more practical way she
wasn't interested in the how or the why
of scp-914's inner workings nor who had
built it her experiments were born out
of considering better usages for the
Clockworks it was a machine that could
provide endless possibilities and Myra
was determined to make it to the fullest
use of it in order to solve actual real
world problems imagine for a moment she
announced reading off her cue cards as
she practiced pitching her experiment to
the foundation's senior researchers
imagine in a world where nobody ever
gets sick or human beings are able to
live long healthy and prosperous lives
maybe dial back on the Star Trek her
colleague research assistant Jensen
interjected really that's what you call
constructive criticism she retorted
before continuing if we apply the
transformative refinement powers of
scp-914 that world could be the future
that awaits us for example I'm proposing
tests that involve placing man-made
chemical compounds like painkillers
heart medication and other potentially
life-saving medicines through the
Clockworks refinement process I'm not
suggesting we need to set it to very
fine and create anomalous versions of
these things but what if even on the
fine setting we're able to improve the
effectiveness of our existing treatments
for all kinds of afflictions Jensen
raised their hand patiently waiting to
comment like a child in a classroom what
a few things they replied lowering their
hand first off some if not all man-made
medications include some kind of organic
component the o5 council have Vandal yes
I'm fully aware of the containment
procedures Mira interrupted them that's
exactly why I'm trying to convince the
council or how just even Dr bright to
let me step around I genuinely believe
we could be doing so much more with
scp-914 and I need them to see that look
I'm not here to rain on your parade
Smithy her assistant reassured I'm only
bringing up concerns that anyone will
have about this proposal you talked
about wanting to improve our existing
Medical Treatments which is Noble don't
get me wrong but have you considered the
wider effect that might have if you make
everyone on Earth more resistance or
even immune to everything then diseases
are going to evolve what if we end up
with a form of super bacteria resistant
to all forms of medication even if that
medicine's been refined in scp-914
trying to save the world might just
bring about its end I've thought about
that but if the console starts allowing
for biological testing again then the
solution is obvious we use the
Clockworks to eradicate whatever germs
diseases are able to develop after
improving treatment options Myra
explained then adding besides that can't
be any more dangerous than what we've
been using scp-914 for I mean enhancing
other scps that's a recipe for disaster
got to agree with you there Jensen side
even without placing them in the
Clockworks the foundation's been way too
Cavalier with the Dangerous Ones
speaking of you know what tonight is
Smithy replied with a confused look date
night they stated elsewhere in the
facility a known to researcher Smithy at
that time one of the dangerous scps
Jensen had mentioned had been let out of
containment this was a regular
occurrence even if it was considered a
little unorthodox to some in fact the
only reason that the o5 council so often
turned a blind eye to it was because of
the researcher it involved Dr Alto cleff
it seemed clef had a certain fondness
for SCP-173 the sculpture a living
statue constructed from concrete and
rebar that could travel at impossible
speeds whenever it was unobserved most
Friday nights clef would have romantic
candlelit dinners with SCP-173 putting a
dress and blonde wig on the sculpture
and treating it like his beloved partner
the whole while watched by Dr clef and a
group of d-class acting as waiters and
Cooks
SCP-173 would stand motionless while the
bizarre date went on late into the night
it was no secret that the sculpture was
a highly aggressive creature with a
penchant for snapping the neck of the
nearest person the moment that they
blinked however it was only because of
Dr clef's reputation and track record
for the elimination of anomalies that he
was granted the special privilege of
whining and dining with SCP-173 this
time though partway through their
regularly scheduled date Dr cleff was
called away to deal with matters
relating to another anomaly he'd been
charged with decommissioning the pair of
d-class waiting on the doctor and his
date were instructed to wait keep a
close eye on SCP-173 alerting each other
in case they needed to Blink it was a
hell of a gamble a risk that could have
been avoided if the sculpture had been
transported back to its secure
containment chamber but Dr clef could be
persuasive that is to say he threatened
both d-class Waiters with the
bludgeoning from his ukulele if they
didn't do as he asked both the d-classes
stared directly at the sculpture each
one feeling the anxious beads of sweat
slowly crawling down their foreheads
worried that they'd both blink at the
same time by accident they announced
their need to refresh their eyes every
so often alternating between being The
Watcher and the one allowed to Blink all
the while as cp-173 was motionless
perhaps it was patiently waiting for Dr
clef to return or for one of the d-class
watching to slip up as if through some
cruel twist of fate a fly began to buzz
through the air drifting towards the
d-class with their eyes on SCP-173 it
looped and darted around its wings
making an annoying droning one of the
waiters announced he needed to Blink
again and the other told him he was free
to do so while he kept watch over the
sculpture at the exact same moment that
one may and blinked the Flies zipped its
way towards the second d-class
distracting him again and drawing his
gaze for a little more than a
millisecond that fly whizzing pass was
the last thing he saw as SCP-173 darted
forward it moved with such incredible
speed that it was imperceptible grabbing
the nearby d-class the one who'd spotted
the fly and killing him instantly before
the other could even open his eyes when
he did SCP-173 had vanished from its
spot at the date night table nowhere to
be seen before the remaining d-class
could realize it was behind him
SCP-173 had made short work of its other
Observer it began zipping unseen through
the corridors of the SCP Foundation
facility Dr clef had returned to his
date only to find the two d-class
waiters dead and SCP-173 missing
immediately he had raised the alarm
meaning that research staff were too
busy fleeing to safely pay any attention
to the sculpture quickly making its way
through the site swept up in the
evacuation Half deafened by by the
alarms in all the commotion researcher
Myra Smithy hadn't even realized she
left the door to the Clockworks wide
open shuffling down a corridor with her
fellow researchers the light suddenly
went out a few nearby screamed in panic
at having been unceremoniously thrust
into the dark Myra blindly reached for
Jensen's hand only to hear the sounds of
multiple heavy concrete feet dragging
along the floor suddenly the emergency
lights blinked she turned and to her
horror she saw SCP-173 with its Stony
arms around Jensen's neck their face
stricken with sheer Terror Tears in
their eyes but now Myra quickly realized
as the corridor was filled with shrieks
of fear from the other researchers that
there was more than one sculpture now
Myra barely managed to escape with her
life and all the confusion crawling out
of the low-lit corridor on her hands and
knees while the multiple new SCP-173
instances slaughtered anyone that
couldn't see them since then she had
been hiding hearing the scraping Style
maps of the sculptures traveling around
the facility unobserved they had
attacked the fuse boxes first as if in a
calculated tactical move take out the
lights and suddenly everyone found it
much harder to see them even through the
fear it was hard for Mira not to blame
herself for all the chaos she couldn't
remember whether she'd left the door to
scp-914 open or not but it hadn't taken
her long to figure out that the
Clockworks had something to do with this
madness somehow SCP-173 had made its way
there had been able to operate the
Machinery while the foundation staff
were distracted by their own evacuation
presumably with scp-914 set to very fine
the sculpture had been transformed into
its ultimate refined form or multiple
forms it seemed there was a veritable
horde of scp-173s running amok through
the facility it made sense Myra reasoned
in some Twisted cruel anomalous way the
sculpture had only ever been a danger
when unobserved the second anyone took
their eyes off of it so much has blinked
it would strike how does a machine like
scp-914 improve upon that easy it gives
the sculpture the power to replicate
itself anyone can look at multiple
things at once of course but nobody can
look at everything simultaneously even
if someone was watching a pair or three
scp-173s one more could easily slip up
behind them for the kill still hidden
under the table Myra's eyes were locked
on the pair of sculptures in the mess
hall the body of the security officer
out of focus in her peripheral vision
she dared not look away Frozen in sheer
fear that the second she blinked they
would lift up the table and find her she
had been so overwhelmed so paralyzed
with her Terror that she had forgotten
about the lights as the emergency
lighting flickered again the sculptures
both moved shifting across the mess hall
as the room went dark only to stop and
place the second Myra could see them
again they hadn't gotten closer in fact
both look to be leaving the only thing
keeping them here was her she was
watching them and it had Frozen them in
place their greatest strength the
imperceptible movement and speed of
SCP-173 was offset by an indisputable
weakness of their anomalous biology they
couldn't stop someone from looking at
them and couldn't stop themselves
becoming still solid concrete when they
were being watched mulling over her
options Myra decided to follow through
with the plan from the Fallen security
guard to retrieve
scp-3108 and try to undo what the
Clockworks had done slowly she slipped
out from under the table keeping both
eyes on the pair of sculptures keeping
them lashed to one spot as she gradually
backed out of the mess hall the lights
went out and plunged the area Into
Darkness again and researcher Smithy
could hear the heavy concrete scraping
of the two sculptures looking for her as
she blindly made her way through the
facility she managed to evade the
roaming Stone creatures resisting her
natural instinct to hide and looking
directly at any she encountered on the
way making sure to stay out of their
view if she saw them she'd freeze them
if they saw her they'd chase her
eventually fishing scp-3108 out of a
containment box Myra held the weapon in
her hand it was a heavily modified Nerf
gun which she loaded a foam dart into
and pulled the plastic slide back the
creatively named nerfing gun had almost
the opposite effect of scp-914 instead
of improving Something
scp-3108 Turned whatever was shot with
it into an inferior equivalent object
something worse than itself it just
might work drawing the gun as she heard
the sound of scraping concrete getting
nearer and nearer Myra turned the corner
coming face to face with one of the
sculptures she held the gun High closing
the gap between them making sure she
didn't miss but wary she needed to fire
before the lights blinked off again she
squeezed the plastic trigger sending the
foam darts shooting out of the barrel of
the nerfing gun the flimsy projectile
guided with the SCP-173 instance
bouncing off its head and landing on the
floor for a split second the light
dimmed again then came back on Myra's
heart had lurched in her chest only to
see that the sculpture hadn't moved at
all she leaned closer to it blinking
intentionally it still didn't move it
was rooted to the ground fixed just a
statue rendered powerless by the nerfing
gun excitedly Myra knelt down and
scrabbled on the floor to retrieve the
dart just as the emergency lighting
flickered out again in her excitement
Myra was too focused on reloading as
cp3108 that is until she heard the
shuffling of concrete and rebar behind
her the lights were still out and she
fumbled blindly for the foam dart as the
noise got closer and closer her
fingertips brushed the projectile
knocking it further away when suddenly
the lights came back up but as she
reached for it researcher Smithy felt a
large cold presence behind her something
huge and heavy and made of stone and
lingering at the very corner of her eye
before she could turn around and face it
something and grabbed Myra and a
sickening snap rang out through the
corridor now go check out scp-096 versus
SCP-173 and SCP-173 origin story how 173
got to site 19. just be careful not to
Blink